are you the one hovering around the chef
at a barbecue do you add bacon to every
salad
if you're one to give in to your
carnivorous instincts
it makes you wonder what if you
only ate red meat would you
increase your risk of cancer are there
any nutrients in meat
that aren't in vegetables
and could eating too much red meat
affect your memory
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you only ate red meat
humans desire to consume the flesh of
mammals is
nothing new in fact
the livestock industry produces 53
billion kilograms of cattle and buffalo
meat annually
to feed our global appetite whether
we're grilling in our backyard or
grabbing fast food on the run red meat
is a staple in most of our diets
but if you were consuming such high
amounts of protein
every day how would your body react
okay let's set up some rules on this
diet
we're only eating red meat no carbs
no veggies and only water to drink
if you order a burger hold the bun the
cheese and
give your friends the fries and don't
think about adding
salt either all your nutrients
will come from protein and
let's make one thing clear red meat
is meat that comes from a mammal despite
what the commercials told you in the 90s
pork is definitely not the other white
mate
so go ahead and enjoy your bacon-wrapped
steak
just try not to burn the meat when you
sear it
if you cook red meat at high
temperatures
it might trigger the production of
compounds that cause
bowel cancer burnt or charred pieces
could contain more carcinogens the
chemicals that cause cancer
to reduce the risk use gentler cooking
methods like
stewing or steaming if you grill you'd
need to keep the meat away from the
exposed flame and
flip it more often to prevent burning
and you're going to have to be a bit
more selective when
ordering out if you want to stay
remotely healthy
since the world health organization
classifies processed meats as
carcinogenic you might want to lay off
the hot dogs
a 2019 study published in the
international journal of epidemiology
found that consuming more than 76 grams
of processed or
red meat each day increases the chance
of developing
colorectal cancer by 20 percent
if you want to stay on this red meat
only diet
it's best to eat free-range grass-fed
livestock
so stay clear of the frozen food aisle
and of packaged meats
fresh red meat contains vitamins like
b12 that
aren't found in plants and forget about
buying those pricey workout supplements
fresh red meat is also rich in creatine
and carnosine so you'd be getting
nutrients that promote muscle
and brain function and grass-fed beef is
even more nutritious than grain-fed beef
containing plenty of heart-healthy
omega-3s
but without any other source of fiber in
your diet
your body could start to go through some
painful changes in the beginning
you'd become constipated and feel
intense
abdominal pain eating only red meat
would create a buildup of uric acid and
your body would form kidney stones
drinking more water will lower your
chance of forming these hard deposits
made of salts and minerals
another fairly obvious risk would be
your increased
chance of heart disease the amount of
cholesterol in your bloodstream
would rise to a dangerously unhealthy
level
this growing mass of plaque on blood
vessel walls
called atherosclerosis could lead to a
heart attack
or even a stroke a 2011
study from the harvard school of public
health found that
men who ate more than two servings of
red meat daily
had a 28 higher risk of having a stroke
than men who ate about one-third of a
serving each day
add to that red meat produces a high
acidic load that's difficult for your
body to absorb
you would become a perfect incubator for
disease
but this carnivorous lifestyle might
help you
lose weight and eating lean meat
would reduce your hunger pangs your
cravings might go down
so you eat less maybe because you'd be
sick of meat
of course your new menu items won't be
cheap
on average conventional beef will cost
about 11 dollars per kilogram
compare that to the same amount of
grass-fed
organic beef which will be around 17
and although eating well could break
your bank
it's not the biggest price you'll pay
with the high level of iron building up
in your body
you might develop alzheimer's disease
and by limiting your diet to red meat
you wouldn't be getting the nutrients
from plants that help you fight
blemishes on your skin
you would increase your chance of
getting a disease
and you'd be more likely to get a cancer
that
you could have prevented but nutritional
science
isn't perfect or exact
it can take years to fully understand
the consequences of diets
so pay attention to what your body tells
you
now if you've burnt your mouth on a
grilled steak
you might want to cool it down a bit
so what if you ate a brick
of dry ice well
that's a story for another
what if
you